sorties scolaires dans la centrale
nucléaire de chinon ce groupe
d'étudiants ingénieurs est venu visiter
edf 1 clé communément appelée la boule
mise en service en 1963 ce réacteur et
le premier construit en france pour le
civil il est aussi le seul à avoir cette
forme si particulière dans le circuit
prime 1 à l'époque il y avait du gaz
carbonique qui circulait et en cas de
fuite de gaz carbonique on pensait qu'il
y aurait une meilleure répartition de la
pression dans une forme sphérique donc
elle est justifiée cette sphère par un
souci de sécurité
à l'arrêt depuis 1973 le démantèlement
de cette centrale a été suspendue la
salle des commandes a été légèrement
relooké
mais le matériel date bien des années 60
ce qui a vraiment pas content c'est la
salle des commandes car ici on peut voir
des traceurs enregistreurs à papier
alors que maintenant on utilise plutôt
des écrans numériques et on se dit que à
l'époque ont contrôlé un réacteur grâce
à du papier et un crayon et ça c'est
assez impressionnant puis au pied du
réacteur c'est le vertige d'immenses
tube s'entremettre jusqu'au sommet et
tout autour la sphère englobe des
cumines jusqu'à 40 mètres de hauteur
soit l'équivalent d'un quatorzième étage
une performance technique au dessus de
vous donc huit fils de quinze et
changeur de chaleur un échangeur de
chaleur ça c'est impressionnant ça fait
29 mètres de haut
63 cm de diamètre et un échangeur de
chaleur pèse 17 tonnes et demie et donc
il y à 120 échangeurs de chaleur au
sommet du réacteur l'étudiant entrevoit
les anciens canaux de graphite
témoin d'une ancienne technologie
française aujourd'hui abandonné la
voulait une puissance de 70 mégawatts
heure aujourd'hui un réacteur moderne
produit 13 fois plus d'électricité
ouverte tout au long de l'année aux
visites d'entreprises et aux scolaires
la boule accueille le grand public une
fois par an à l'automne edf souhaite
augmenter le nombre de visites et
projette aussi de créer un outil
pédagogique sur le démantèlement des
centrales nucléaires